the first Nigerians evacuated from South
Africa have arrived back in the country
hundreds of Nigerians signed up for free
flights home following a wave of
violence against foreigners in South
Africa they're reporting violent attacks
on themselves their businesses their
properties but while there is relief at
having escaped many say they are
uncertain what the future holds for them
at home
our correspondent funny future reports
from Lagos slowly and with the long
delay it finally arrives the airplane
from Johannesburg journalists and some
officials are waiting for the passengers
to disembark this is the first machine
from South Africa with Nigerian
returnees the first since anti-immigrant
violence erupted in and around
Johannesburg last week now that the
Nigerians are back what does the future
hold for them a warm welcome to begin
with but a lot of uncertainty too this
woman left South Africa after seven
years because of the xenophobic attacks
she says she has brought her child with
her it brings my car I've got the papers
here so personally the experience was
good so what's the plan for your future
now what are you going to do now are you
hoping to forge ahead probably find a
job because I'm a graduate in only
government can provide my job hours
earlier and just outside of the airport
the usual hustle in Lagos Nigeria is
facing chronic unemployment especially
among its youth just like South Africa
this young man studied to be an
accountant but can only survive
repairing cars he believes the future is
bleak for the returnees I feel so sorry
for them because they're coming back the
government they don't have any plan for
them
even we that we are here no plan for us
we just have to plan for ourselves so we
are they going to start from a question
that a senior assistant of President
Buhari is eager to answer the government
has been criticized for not doing enough
for the returnees a private airline
chose to volunteer to bring some of them
home one of the major problems we see in
this situation is communication so
they're going to have SIM cards with
airtime that will last them for two
months there is not what these people
want to hear 189 people arrived on the
first plane tired exhausted and Confused
expecting more from the government our
government needs to provide some things
for us like electricity water and good
roads you understand me that's what
South African as that we are stained a
very basic needs to start a business
like they had in South Africa where they
could make a living but were they no
longer feel welcome